I think the most pressing and important
question is this first one from Tomas
Grannis about Lego yes what's your
favorite Lego theme yeah my favourite
lega theme is something that not a lot
of people know it's called ideas okay
and so basically you can submit if you
have an idea of a new Lego said that
should be built then people can vote and
then if it gets enough votes then they
build it and so one of the set that I
just got is three birds since boring
they're actually super beautiful mm-hmm
and they came from a random person
submitting this idea that's so cool I
was just reading an AMA the other day
with a Lego master builder did you see
that one on reddit yeah yeah you
probably knew all that what kind of
birds are they
I so that will be really hard for me to
not tell you in French yeah that's next
level in my learning of English so so I
know what fern is just because I've been
around I see but for for the average
person who doesn't know what it is how
would you describe it
so I would describe it as a shared inbox
so you can think about it as you know
what Gmail or outlook does but we've
added collaboration features and
workflows so that it works it works
better for teams so we have a few
different kinds of teams that are using
the product from recruiting team support
team zakah management teams client
services teams operations teams and what
they have in common is they have a lot
of emails coming in and inside their
company a lot of people inside the team
that needs to handle these emails and
they struggle managing that as a team
because email wasn't made for teams mhm
that's what we do and when did you add
the the personal email to it actually
pretty early on yes the thing is it
wasn't working that well so meeting you
weren't getting users yeah meaning in
order to have a product that people used
for their individual emails you need to
get to a level of feature parity with
Gmail or Outlook that's pretty intense
and so even if you could do it four
years ago it's only about two years ago
that we started having the features that
would allow people to manage both
shared in boxes and individual in boxes
as well so today we have I think 40% of
our daily active users who are using
front both for shared in boxes and
individual inboxes hmm and we're
releasing a brand new version of front
at the end of October that we've been
working on for nine months and the goal
is to make sure that people can enjoy
the individual inbox as much as they
enjoy the shared inbox can you be more
specific meaning so today when you have
a shared inbox let's say support ad
sales ads it's obvious that they require
collaboration otherwise you would not
have a shared networks but for
individual inbox so met electronic and
they also require collaboration so I
will collaborate with my assistant with
our sales team and specific deals with
our recruiting team and specific
candidates with our product team and
product feedback and if so tomorrow with
France you can also add your individual
inbox metal at front app and then
assignment messages have internal
conversations around these messages
integrate it with whatever tool you're
using github Salesforce Trello asana
etcetera so it becomes a full
replacement for Gmail or outlook gotcha
okay how do you feel about a Gmail or
rather Google wrapping up Inbox
I think it's zero surprising so I mean
so first of all I wasn't a huge fan of
Inbox
I think inbox brought a few things that
were great like the grouped
notifications they had great snooze
features but I think that if you want
people to change how they deal with
email the amount of innovation that you
need to bring needs to be super high
because it's very disruptive to change
so then the value proposition needs to
be like it needs to be 10x better and I
didn't feel like inbox was 10x better
than Jimmy hmm so I know surprised and
then when they rolled out their new
gmail version and like you could see
that it was pretty similar then I I knew
that that was coming it kind of brought
over the better stuff yeah and and then
also if you are going to have two
different products doing the same thing
then they should be super different hmm
and they weren't super different hmm did
you find that when when you started to
integrate individual emails into front
the
people were asking for like all these
like vestigial features of Gmail that
you're like this is gonna be ended at
some point but they still want it yeah I
think there are you know there are so
yes they want a lot of features but I
think that's normal and we should
provide them there are a few ones that
are harder to implement just because I
can't be convinced that they're better
for the world so for example you know
subset folder is like hey and you can
try to build a click again and maybe the
thing or maybe it's not yeah hmm okay
how did you end up weighing that out
like it was just if enough customers
complained that you're enough people
like gave you friction about signing up
you would build it so and the question I
I saw that a lot of people asked on
Twitter questions about how do you
prioritize features so like I can took a
little bit more about that so there is
one thing that's unique that we did
which is so it is in YC 4 years ago we
built a Trello roadmap man we made it
public so we're like here is everything
we're thinking about building and you
can avoid the thing that you want and
you can see what we're working on and
you can see what has been shipped so
that gave us a ton of insight and what
people wanted the second thing that we
did was so obviously we use front to
manage incoming inquiries but any tool
that you're using should be able to
provide analytics on the kind of request
that your users have so you should be
able to see in the past month
for example I don't 20% of incoming
inquiries were about folders or a better
analytics or whatever so then we can
look at that and then arrives the moment
where like you have so many inputs plus
that's there is also what I personally
believe we should build and you need to
make a decision and I feel like the
decision will be will be based on two
things one is what's the intensity or
how much complexity it is to build a
certain feature and then is like what's
the uptake like what can we expect from
it well it
I don't know increase our market will it
make our current users happier will they
pay more etcetera and so you always need
to balance these two things and
for us we just have a scale of 1 to 3 so
like in terms of how good it will be for
users 1 2 3 like game changer or like
slightly better nice to have yeah and
then how complex is it's to build and so
then you have 9 different scores
depending on these three things and
that's how we can prioritize what we
built and we should always put that in
perspective of what our won with our
vision is and making sure that were not
doing something that's against what we
want to build and then making sure that
we remain focused because I think that
one of the biggest thing that you need
to achieve when you're small is being
super focused hmm and of those features
you've rolled out in the past four years
were there certain ones where you really
notice the giant uptick and usage or
growth or yeah yeah so there is a there
is one one way that we were really used
where it's really changed how font was
used so and it's specific to what we do
but basically the concept of frontiers
whenever you have a message that comes
in you can comment on it so you have an
email and you can have internal
discussions about it you have the tweets
you can have internal discussions about
it and so before you could comment on
one specific message so if you had
extrema sieges you could decide to
comment on message 1 or message 2 or
message 3 the bad thing about that is it
was really hard to have a conversation
that was flowing because you could
comment on message 1 and then someone
come into my email came out yeah exactly
yeah and so but we wanted to let people
have conversations that were fluid
around so we decided to do two things
one is reverse the order of
conversations so now the most recent is
that at the bottom and not at the top
and then that would allow us who have
conversations not associated to any
message anymore but that would just flow
into the conversation mmm
and so that was a huge disruption
because when people use email like 5
hours a day and they've built workflows
around
commenting on messages and you're
introducing the huge shims that are
pretty upset but then what we saw is the
number of comments that was made per
daily active users that was during that
way and then he
through that way and so I feel like most
of the decisions product decision that
we made that led to like a significant
change in behavior yeah where is the
most painful mmm and another example is
we're releasing a new version of France
in October like I can't tell you how
upset our customers are gonna be and I
don't tell you how excited I am that
we're rolling this out but it's going to
be super disruptive so a bunch of people
had questions about like how you guys
were when you know getting customers in
the early days so I think what would be
helpful is for context like what did
front look like when you guys launched
because I'm sure it's different now yeah
I mean so the front sucked when we
launched it okay remember we were in YC
and our batch mates would come to me and
ask can I use the product and I was like
no you should like our product is
written that is great so like it wasn't
great but you should lunch it's like as
soon as possible because that's how
you'll get feedback and that's you want
feedback in order to make sure that
you're making something people want so
the product was bad now what I remember
is building an MVP in the email space
stuff because people expect a lot of
features like they will expect
attachments to work they will expect
tags to work you should be able to see
see people be see see people forward
emails etc so basically what we did was
we had that like the most basic version
up front without attachments like but we
would still try to see if some
innovation that we had brought where you
could assign emails to people and have
comments would be enough for people to
give up on a few of the features and I
remember that something that we did when
front was super early is I was writing a
lot of content and so I think probably
our first 300 customers were coming from
content that I was writing on like
medium or and then sharing on Hacker
News or guest posts or on our blog and
writing about email which I think was a
topic that people liked reading about or
the communication collaboration slack
and then people would sign
to our beta and then I would call them
and manually unbought them and try to
have them use the product and then they
would use the product for maybe a few
hours and then stop using the product
but then I would know why then I would
you know it took my co-founder and tell
him for one feature away like a
deterrence and and and then we're good
and we'd build it and then I talk to
customers and they were like no that's
missing one feature away and we're
really the only things we did for the
first year at least was just doing that
it was writing contents on boarding
users and building features and every
other distraction that you could think
of yeah we didn't do okay so I was
emailing with Wade from zapier yeah
about their content marketing Kat and I
are doing a class start of school this
week yeah and one thing he said which is
that was really interesting was in the
beginning they found themselves getting
trapped by writing content that would do
well on Hacker News
yeah but not actually convert to users
for them yeah were you able to
differentiate that in the beginning or
were you just trying to get any kind of
attention so it might be true the truth
he is like first of all I had no other
idea so yes in an ideal world I would
find a legion source that's as effective
as possible yeah I knew nothing about
ped equation
Sharon Vox is not something people are
looking for so I felt like that wasn't
working we had a horizontal product and
we weren't sure who were who was going
to use it so like out bounding wasn't
necessarily the best thing because
you're like we have this general tool
and so for me yes the truth is I would
agree with them like we I think for more
beta we had 3,000 companies that signed
up to to our products and I think I
don't know 10 of them ended up using our
product so the conversion rate is not
high but anytime I was unborn someone
and the person was not interested I'd
learnt a ton and so if I were to do it
again I think I would do it again just
because that was my
yes have a lot of people setting up and
then I had a few tricks like whenever
you were signing up you had an
auto-reply that said why are you why are
you interested what problem are you
trying to solve and so even if you know
they don't end up converting then you
get a ton of information mmm
so at skill constant is not at all how
we get users today but in the early days
our it is it's still some the way we get
users but not the main source which is
which is paid acquisition versus in the
early days it was the main source for us
to get users and I don't regret it I
don't think it was scalable but I think
it was doable and confronted us with the
market what was the most successful
piece it's like you know well last
forever yeah okay so it's kind of like
this opinionated let's say it was a lot
of leadership and a lot of sharing my
journey as a founder and how far did
that get you so you know you said you
know out of 3,000 companies you got 10
maybe how did you get two we hired our
first marketing person in January 2017
so two and a half years after we
launched the product so that's where it
got us so PR and content was 90 percent
of what we did in the first two and a
half years which is how many customers
roughly so it got us to probably 1
million in AR and so that was probably a
thousand customers maybe something like
that that's great yeah Wow um listen
that this customers yes 500 it's you you
guys started making this in some kind of
like startup lab thing right wasn't oh
yeah yeah can you talk more about that
because we haven't had someone on the
podcast that's been through one of those
yeah so when I graduated I
a drainer startup and then I knew that I
wanted to start a company but I think
for me the main thing is I had to borrow
money to go to school and then I had to
give back the money and starting a
company was pretty tough so I took a job
in a SAS company and I was doing sales
because I feared that I could probably
make a lot of money if I was doing my
job
right and so two things happen one is I
made some money so that was good in two
is I learned more about SAS and
software's and I loved it
like I really loved the idea of building
a product that could then be used by
some people and then their life at work
would be drastically different because
of a product that we had built so it was
at that point I was working on a
contract management software and
contracts or super archaic and then they
had this beautiful tool and I said it
was wonderful but I was not using
contracts I was using email and I was as
frustrated with his tool that had not
evolved in the past ten years was
clearly wasn't made for businesses so a
year after I joined the company I was
lucky enough to meet with this so there
are called a founders there are a
start-up studio and what they do is they
either find technical co-founders or
business co-founders and they try to
have people miss and then if you know a
great relationship comes out of it then
they are happy to fund them and so
that's where I met with my co-founder
long and so when I think about my
journey at front like where I got most
like he was meeting with them with him
and with them five years ago and so I
met him and for two months
how did you meet was it some kind of
like speed dating situation no it's like
they host events I eventually quit my
job and so I spend a lot of time in
there sort of studio helping on lots of
different projects and loja was there
and it was same thing like he had quit
his job was working on one specific
project met him and then really liked
him
and I think the thing that we tried to
do for two months was asking ourselves
all these tough questions that can
happen in the journey of two founders
like what happens if I want to fire you
or you want to fire me or you want to
sell and I don't want to sell or like
whatever should we have the same
ownership in the company and things like
that like would you move to San
Francisco and and I think we agreed on
everything and so then after two months
were like okay let's do it and it worked
out so well so it was super lucky but so
I think for us startup studio was great
for two reasons one the fact that we met
and to the fact that we got initial
funding now a few months after we met we
decided to good whoo I see where we get
additional funding and so then we
weren't very close to them so was super
great in the first few months and then
why she was great and then other things
were great everything's great a
different stage of the company
yeah I'm sure things were painful too
yeah yeah yeah so did the idea come
about before you even joined at the
intersection of two things one is I was
willing to innovate in the email space
and Laura my co-founder had been in two
companies before where they had a lot of
users they were forced to implement
helpdesk solutions like Zendesk or
freshdesk astre hated them and so like
what he wanted to build was a
lightweight support tool and so in fact
like France started as this email tool
but with a good market being shared
inboxes and the reason was because don't
want you to do that aren't you do that
with it okay but you know it's
impossible to start from scratch like no
company has managed to build a business
starting with an email product because
super hard to build super hard to have
people pay for it so I was like okay
what if the good market is shared in
boxes but then we expand as we discussed
into like a full email client that can
be used by individuals and
and that's why Frank is this combination
of like this very big vision but this
very simple pain points that we address
at the beginning mmm just to go back
really quickly what have been the
hardest moments so far up front yeah I
mean so I can share one that's
business-related then one that's more
personal so 18 months ago my co-founder
was diagnosed with cancer so that was
the hardest moment by far and so then
when I reflect on the journey you know
it's really hard to say this moment
where I don't know we didn't get the
term sheet we wanted or like this
because in return like it's really hard
for me to tell that you lose them like
hardest moment because that's far harder
than anything you can conceive and now
is great and so all of it was turned out
in a super positive outcome but I think
when that happened it was like my lowest
and then you start to realize that you
know like founders are always very
committed to making their company work
and it's good but they should also
realize that you know their company is
just a company and you have a life
outside of your company that's also
super important and you should enjoy
every moment that you have because you
know things could be very different
tomorrow yeah and how do you how do you
maintain that balance you mean you like
good friend of Legos play soccer so I
mean I'm so when I'm super deliberate
myself and then I tried to implement a
lot of things at front who promote this
healthy work-life balance and clearly
it's been influenced by the fact that
long got sick and so I personally
meditate every day I log out of every
app slack front it's dry every weekend
and anytime I'm on PTO I don't have any
notifications so I'm never distracted by
by work and then I exercise like I play
soccer I run I Kate surf I bike and I
just make sure that it's like when
stay late at the office it's an
exception I sometimes do it and when I
work during the weekend it's an
exception as well so that's what I do
personally in order to make sure and I
sleep like at least eight hours a night
every night that was like the biggest
game-changer for me actually I'm feeling
better I know it's like so dumb and
obvious but it's like prioritizing that
yeah for sure
oh isn't it always felt more proactive
and then you know as France they are if
you think so last week we had health and
wellness week and every day you could
meditate so that you could understand
what it does and then we had lunch and
nuran explaining the impact of eating
healthy on your emotions and I don't
know we organized a few runs and so yeah
also whenever people join I explain what
fun is about and I explained that I care
about it so that's you know our culture
as well yeah and you're just kind of try
and lead by example yeah in the same way
yeah yeah and in the hard moment for
your company
what was that I mean so the thing is so
every single moment is super hard and so
one of my biggest learnings from YC four
years ago when you know the company was
super small and every Tuesday we had
people coming and talking about all
kinds of things and we had the founders
of stripe of Facebook of opportunity of
Dropbox like which are super successful
companies and they were telling us how
hard it was and how many times they've
wondered whether the business would go
anywhere I mean that's the story of my
life like you know it's super easy to
think about France as you know this
company that has you look at our metrics
because I've published everything we've
consistently been doing well in terms of
revenue our retention of employees is
high Lou could you look at our funding
stories we've always raised money super
easily okay cool like that's what you
can read about it the truth is every
single day I wake up and there is a list
of ten questions where I don't have
answers and I need to figure them out
and I know that the more we grow the
more is at stake and so I absolutely
need to find the answers and so every
single day is hard and we still have
customers that Shirin and I'm extremely
sad about it we still have employee
situations that are not easy to deal
with I still have you know moments where
I'm wondering if we should do what we're
doing and that's true for every single
founder I've ever met as successful as
they are and so I think nobody should
wonder whether like it's hard or easy
like it's just consistently hard and do
you need help reminding yourself of that
or where the dinner is enough um no I
read you know the hard things about how
things and every lot of founders have
read the book but for me it was like
really game-changer to just read about
the fact that it's hard you should stop
wondering about it yeah just a given
doesn't mean anything about the health
of your company
yeah so I just need to remind myself
that it's normal and it's just a drug
yeah yeah you you said something
interesting about retention I know
that's like something you guys are
particularly good at and proud of I'm
sure yes um do you have kind of pro tips
in that category yeah
so I'm preparing it talk about that so I
I've been thinking about it so here is I
think it's a super complex questions
because if the answer was it's now let's
do that so yeah but we have super high
retention and super high NPS inside the
company so I I think that there are
three categories of things you can do
within your company to make sure that
that's happening the first one is like
how do you hook people and I think
that's by having a mission driven
company so at the end of the day so I
was asked to do a talk about retention
and so then I emailed our employees and
it was like the end of the day why are
you engaged motivated happy where do you
work hard and a lot of them were saying
because we care about the mission and
and so I think you need to make sure
that you have a mission it's clear
people can interpret it in the way they
want our mission statement is work
happier and you know it means different
things for different people but if
people can relate to
and can feel like you know they have
purpose when work on front then it's
good so making it super clear and as
your company scale just making sure that
you say it over and over and everyone
knows what it means everyone has
examples of what it means is super
important then I think that the then
there is like the push what will enable
them to go above and beyond and I think
that for that it's really the quality of
co-workers so one advice that Patrick
Allison gave me when I was hiring our
first employees was two things one when
you hire your first employees you should
think about every person that you bring
with a bar that's as high as could this
person be my co-founder and that was
super helpful because then you hire
people that like already great at the
beginning and then the second of advice
he gave me was when you hire someone you
should wonder whether you want 10%
existing in your company because the
truth is they will hire people like them
and so then if you don't want ten people
like this then you should probably not
hire this person and so I think we did a
really good job in the early days at
hiring super talented people that were a
really good match with our values and so
then as we grew the team like I think
the team became really good and good
meaning they're talented but also they
are we have some values we there are low
you go high standards collaborative
caring and and I think that making sure
that even when you're desperate to hire
people you don't lower your bar and
you've heard so much but like it's so
important that's I think something that
contributes to us having a real good
culture and I like to think about every
single employee that we bring as someone
bringing something new on top of you
know all the baseline baseline being
here so that and then the third thing is
I think so people want to see and
understand that they have an impact
because if they care about the vision
and the mission and and they have great
co-workers so they want to do their best
but they don't sure how to contribute
then at the end of the day they were
probably not
do as good of a job or be as happy and
so for that I think there are like a lot
of thing that you can implement within
your company so one of them is
transparency so it's a word that's being
used a lot but it's super easy to claim
that you're a transparent company and
super hard to implement and it gives us
harder as you scale so for us being
transparent means you have dashboards
that show everything every Monday
morning we go over all our metrics every
quarter I do a presentation less quadrat
front I review everything that has been
doing well not going well every board
meeting I send the board deck every I
don't every inbox is accessible in front
so you want to see what customers want
to say like good things and bad things
you can access it if you want to see why
a candidate didn't accept an offer you
can know why like whatever you want to
if you want to know what our runway you
can also know what's our runway and when
you say every inbox is accessible does
that mean personal inboxes as well
no so personal inbox is usually there so
if you are a manager you have access to
your direct reports inboxes and the
truth is I tried we tried to make so we
try to make as many inboxes as possible
public but the truth is you have to
implement some rules because I know
there are HR emails that should not be
shared there are financial emails that
should not be shared so we try to share
as much of the like personal emails
their name at companies come as possible
but not hundred lessons are shared so I
think transparency is just like a really
good way to have people understand
what's the impact of their work is on
all these metrics that are displayed mmm
these are a few tips yeah what else
don't you share so the way I think about
transparency is if something is going to
create more Prime's and raise more
questions then values of transparency is
something is going to answer a lot of
questions and so those are firms then
good use of transparency so what's the
what don't we share we don't share the
salaries of everyone it's why so I can
give you an example
there is like a person at France that
might have health issues and our
insurance doesn't cover it so we might
pay this prison an additional I don't
know a few hundred dollar a month
instead of paying for the insurance and
so then if everything was public and
then people would be like what is this
person paid as much and then I would
have to explain and so that's and I
don't care like it doesn't bring
anything great to the company so the way
I think about compensation is if anyone
knew everything tomorrow I could explain
mm-hmm and it's fear and that's what
matters now it doesn't mean that I will
share it because it's actually not super
helpful and I mean another example is
you know when people leave our let go
usually we don't share why and we try to
be super transparent about our
performance process so that people
understand why someone might be let go
and making sure that it's fair now
privacy of employees is more important
than transparency and so then
transparency doesn't mean that I was
sure this person wasn't good at doing
this is bad and that I would let this
person go right and so do you guys now
have employees overseas as well yes in
France yes so we decided to open an
office in Paris in January this year and
so now we have about 20% of our team in
Paris and 80% here okay and now how do
you go about making them feel included
same thing we're super deliberate about
it so every employee in France starts
with a nun boarding in San Francisco
twice a year we have company-wide off
sites and everyone is coming we have all
hands where we make sure that it's a
balance between SF sharing insights and
Paris sharing insights my co-founder
went back to France so like having one
founder in each team is super important
we have a lot of people from SF who go
to Paris so that they can also share
more about the culture here and so far
it's working really well I mean or still
improving and other things but that's
and he's there full-time now yeah okay
that's great yeah yeah that helps
oh yeah it's hopes the time you got a
ton of questions on Twitter yeah I there
was one that I wanted to bring up now so
KP asks what is one unique insight about
the problem meaning the problem you're
working on you didn't have at the start
but only discovered later after
launching yeah so I think there are a
few things one thing that I always find
interesting is you know one of the
reason why I think we were successful
building an email product and I mean
successful so far is because we actually
had no we didn't have a lot of insights
so you know I had been working for a
year and so it's not a lot and so I
think and my co-founder was very
technical so didn't use email like many
many hours every day or had not built
any email product yeah and I think
having you know a new pair of eyes on
this program that has I mean has existed
for like ever
I think was something that was really
good so you know when people sometimes
ask questions about the insights that
you have and other people don't have
something so something the fact that you
don't have any insight and you have like
a new pair of eyes is actually super
insightful now the truth is everything
that we discovered about France is
things that I didn't know before so for
example we have these use cases were
logistics companies and travel companies
love font I knew nothing about this
industry and now I'm going through
tracking conferences and I understand
exactly how they work and so I think
it's just we've been super super honest
with ourselves on what we knew and what
we didn't know and then talking with our
potential customers so much to
understand their insights and so the way
I would answer this question is the
truth is 99% of what I know today I
didn't know when I started right I just
felt like for sure something could be
improved in that space and I felt like
we had a good team to do it that's the
only thing you okay
I mean you were committed to the problem
to the run but it was I
more about like I want people to be more
efficient at work and I feel like email
is the tool that people use to get work
done and so I care about that more than
you know
adding collaboration to email or
assigning emails or communicant emails
like no I care about people spend their
lives in their inbox yeah and these two
has much involved in the past ten years
and it was not made for businesses so
for sure something can be improved
mmm-hmm CVD how let's start with your
inboxes did you get yeah did you guys
consider other options before you really
started building front no no like we we
knew that we would start with Sharon
inboxes when one funny story that I
sometimes hear when I go to YC for
dinners is we we try to have these
insights like we were looking for them
so for example PB who created Gmail was
is one of the partners that we see and
so when I joined YC I was super excited
to meet with him and I was like so here
are all ideas so we can go in this
direction this search in this direction
what do you think we should do and it
was like follow your growth and I was
like a geek I like it yeah I'm glad I
took to all my friends about the fact
that I was like yeah person created
gmail but at the end of the day that's
the best advice you could give us
because you know he has some insights on
like what prime Gmail was trying to
solve but that's very different from
what Franzese trying to solve and that's
like a different time in in history and
a different set of run yeah I mean he
also well I mean there are multiple ways
tackle this but like there's so much
pattern matching that happens at YC yeah
that like you it's almost like you don't
want to get too prescriptive with this
stuff because you can negatively pattern
yeah yeah the wrong thing yeah so
there's another question
Jordan Jackson asks email at least for
me has taken on a different meaning in
life in the context of like messaging
apps and chat platforms it is almost
more serious in a way how do you see
email evolving and the ecosystem that
encompasses it in
yeah so I mean I think it's a good
question because you hear so much for
from companies likes like for example
email is dead and yeah so here's like
the way thing about email is first of
all for your personal email so like
you're emailing friends and thing is I
don't think that email will last forever
so if you look at the growth you're over
your rates actually decreasing every
year whereas if you look at work emails
it's increasing year over year so I
believe that email will remain in a work
environment I'm not convinced about your
personal life and I think like whatsapp
and Facebook Messenger and all these
other tools can actually be better hmm
or be used for more than they used now
in a work environment
I feel like email the protocol is
actually perfect because it's the only
protocol that you can use to communicate
with people outside your company and so
even if you have great tools like slack
that enable you to slack in to message
people internally yeah
the truth is it will not solve 90% of
your communication which is happening
externally and however I think the
interfaces for email is like on a
perfect so the pro is great interest not
great and so if you have a tool that has
a good interface and can be inspired by
other apps that are doing amazing like
slack his credit is they have a really
delightful product that's really fast
that much cross-platform and I think if
you can apply some of the thing that
maybe is companies or these tools
successful and apply them to a protocol
that in my opinion is the best then I
strongly believe that people could spend
90% of their time in their inbox versus
today it's probably not as high as 90%
no if you could like wipe everyone's
memory of email context and like restart
what would you wipe out and like create
a new like if I was to start a like a
new you could just like delete email
from everyone's mind and just have all
right this is the new email product yeah
so you know I think I would probably
wipe out most of the structural features
because when you
think about you know the main things are
you have a subject you have a signature
you literally carbon copy and blank
carbon could be and so I think I would
remember that so I don't think you need
to subject I don't think you need you
should CC BCC for reply all these things
but I would keep the fact that it's
Universal and you can have a message
that's being sent somewhere else and
then that's what I would do so I would
say would be similar to SMS yeah but
then the tricky thing is SMS is zero
concept of workflow so you still need
workflows and so for example everything
around the fact that you can assign
messages you can share a message and you
can collaborate on a draft you can
comment internally you can create
automation and say if then like that's
super important that doesn't exist in
SMS but today this feature CC BCC for
like are used as workflows yeah whereas
really they're not designed for that so
then that leads to a lot of in
efficiencies okay
so there were just a handful of other
questions about product market fit that
I feel like I think it's funny because
based on the the startup school lectures
I think like the questions are changing
with every week and there were just a
bunch on product market fit when did you
guys feel like you hit it yeah it's a
good question
very late actually so I mean when when
we when we raised our seed we had just
few numbers I think we're doing like
10km are so another lot we might have I
don't know like a hundred companies
using the product and clearly I didn't
feel great yeah I've you know it was
ultimately a good investment but I
didn't feel like we had product market
fit yeah and I think when we raised our
series a and so we raised our series a
we were making I think 1.5 million in a
are so a little bit over 100k Mr I think
that's where when I felt like some
companies were using the product and
even if I had demoed all the alternate
yeah front was actually a better
solution for them and I think that's and
then I felt like the market was big but
didn't really know how big but at least
big enough and I think so that's and so
that was in in three years after we
started it's a pretty dumb thing yeah
took a while yeah and so when founders I
mean imagine like you've given talks and
stuff now people are asking you for
advice and like yeah when they're
looking to find it what do you what do
you tell them what do you or what do you
even point them to ah like based on
product marketed or advice in general
product market fit
so like this thing is at the end of the
day like you need to be convinced that
you're doing something that people want
and so I feel like you need to be and
it's piece of advice that I share in
general like you need to be so brutally
honest with yourself and with your team
about what's working and not working I
think startups are so hard that there is
almost like as a human being it you want
to be happy and so you don't necessarily
want to face every reality because it
can be really hard and so you know if
you were working 12 hours a day and the
thing that you keep hearing is and
that's super interested in your work
whatever and then at a point someone
says it's pretty good then you end
course so much and the fact that someone
said it's pretty good and then you tend
to ignore the fact that yes but 95
percent told you that it was not good
and and so I think you know making sure
that you the only things you do is
talking to people using the product
talking to people that might be
interested in using the product and then
building things so that these two things
can change and then communicating that
or sharing this information with your
team and having one metric in place that
will show you whether you're making
progress or not
so for us it was revenue because we
thought like if you were willing to use
the product they would pay for it that's
the only thing that matters and and
that's the focus you need to have both
like in your head you need to make sure
that you're super honest
and also from just a process and
communication standpoint like you should
make sure that you know every single day
you share how many more users revenue
like whatever you have every single week
you can calculate your growth and you
can look at it cuz I mean I think it's
PG who said that but the first way to
have anything increase is to look at it
and like just be super honest about
about it yeah I think that's your cross
support dealer you're scared of the
truth I'm curious about all this in the
context of your your meditation practice
yeah
what does that look like on a daily
basis and have you been doing this for a
long time so I've been meditating for
every day for I think 500 days so it's
like not forever but now quite a long
time yeah
so I mean 500 days is when maker 406 it
was like a mortar we started it was a
more challenging period of mine F where
I think it was overwhelmed but I think
whether I was over 1 for that reason or
other reasons I think like when you're a
founder in draw I am pretty convinced
that 99.9% of founders would benefit
from meditating every day so that was
the trigger but I wish I had known
before yeah
so the the good thing about meditation
is that as boring as it sounds and you
know I haven't I think an active mine
and I don't like that thinking about
anything for 10 minutes I do 10 minutes
every morning so that's it so yeah again
like your processes let me wake up ya
know say wake up have a shower cause
otherwise I fall asleep when I'm a
beginning so no wake up ok have a shower
and then meditate for 10 minutes do you
meditate you have like a pillow you like
sit down on something what do you do
no I mean I have a couch in my living
room okay and I just sit there great so
immediate 810 is it yeah I just sit and
I have a nap headspace okay so you do a
guided meditation getting meditation and
then tennis and then put my stuff on and
then leave for work how long did you
have to do before you felt that it was
effective so many weeks I think you know
it's nothing
magical it's really like it's really a
muscle that you're training and as
anything like you own this is the
results in probably a few weeks or a few
months then a few arrays are a few days
that really the thing that I get out of
it is now when an issue arise it's like
okay cool the issues here before it was
again so it's 90 percent of what's in my
head it's like taking all my attention
I'm super upset nothing can make me less
upset just because I constantly think
about it and now if you like though I
like a there is a distance like it's
really like headspace is the name and
read what it gave me is more headspace
and I can identify all the think that I
need to do yeah and there are different
elements and doesn't prevent me from
being upset but then I can I feel a
context switch more easily and be in
another state of mind for another set of
problems fascinating right it's awesome
no I've gotten into a little bit I've
always found that like exercise has been
my like a go-to strategy yeah but it's
I've done some meditation it's a little
bit different it's very different yeah I
do yeah
there are only so many hobbies and
habits that you can like motivate
yourself to keep us sure but 10 minutes
a day is something that you can do of
course and and I feel like it's at least
every everyone should try for a few
weeks cuz I feel like it can be such a
game-changer but it's like it's clearly
discipline that you need to have this
really hard web yeah absolutely
but you just got to want it yeah and you
do it yes this has been great thank you
for coming in of course thank you for
having me
you